Stakes are the reason that audiences
become invested in your story.
Stakes are the things that make an
audience worry or wonder, makes them
curious, makes them root for you,
makes them hope for your demise.
Stakes are essential to a story.
They are the things that make people
want to hear the end of the story.
They're the things that drive
people to the end of the story.
There are several types of stakes
that you can deploy in a story,
and all can be very powerful.
The most important stake of all
is what I call the elephant.
I call it the elephant
because it's enormous.
It's enormously important to a story.
The elephant is essentially the initial
signpost to the audience that says,
"This is what my story is about, at
least for now." In a movie, we don't
really need an elephant because what
we have today is movie trailers.
When we go into a movie, we
kinda know what we're gonna see.
If we're going into a Mission Impossible
movie, we know what the stakes are.
The world is in danger and
Tom Cruise must save the day.
When we walk into a romantic
comedy, we know what the stakes
are, what the elephant is.
It is two people are not in love.
Will they be in love by
the end of the movie?
Those are the stakes.
But when we're speaking, telling
a story, delivering a sales pitch,
speaking at a conference, delivering a
keynote, nobody knows really what we're
going to say as we open our mouths.
We need to give them a reason
right away to be invested in that
story with what I call an elephant.
Standing in the playground behind
my school beside this enormous pile
of leaves, and this tiny little hand
comes out of the leaves with a silver
metallic object in it, and the boy
attached to the hand, he says, "Look,
Mr. Dix, a spoon." And it, it's a spoon.
It's a ordinary kitchen spoon,
probably fell out of a lunchbox
earlier that day or 10 years ago.
But I say, "No, Jamie, that's the spoon
of power." And now that I've declared
it to be the spoon of power, I must
have it because that is who I am.
And Jamie knows this.
I can see it on the look in his face,
and he knows that I know it, and I
know that he knows that I know it,
and all of this is true 'cause he's
running before he says anything else.
And the 74 kids that I'm supposed
to be monitoring closely are lost
to me, and the only thing I focus
on is a little redheaded boy with
a spoon that I must now have.
And we run across the field, and we
climb up the slide and through the
tubes, and 17 minutes later, the bell
rings, and that little boy still has
the spoon, and I can't believe it.
The spoon of power.
It's a very similar
elephant to the beginning.
A spoon has made an appearance
in a little boy's hand, and
Matt must now have that spoon.
Will he get the spoon?
That is the elephant that I present
at the beginning of the story.
It's actually the elephant or the
stake that carries us through much
of the story until he eventually
puts it on a chain around his neck,
and then the elephant changes.
It's it's 1991, and I'm 20 years old,
and I'm driving home from the very
first booty call of my entire life.
And I am excited because I don't know
that this is going to also be the very
last booty call of my entire life.
And then it's in that moment of excitement
that the right front tire of my 1976 Chevy
Malibu blows out, but it doesn't deflate.
It disintegrates.
It throws rober- rubber on the road in
a way that I didn't think was possible,
and it takes everything I can to get the
car over to the shoulder and to a stop.
And it's 1991.
I don't have a cell phone,
so I do the only thing I can.
I start hiking up the
road to look for help.
Seven hours later, after giving all
of my money to a half-naked mountain
man named Winston, I have a bald
tire on my car, and I'm heading
home when I look at the instrument
panel, and I see that I have no gas.
And all of the money that I
have is in Winston's hand.
And it's 1991.
I don't have a credit card.
I don't have an ATM card.
I don't even have a checking account.
And so I take the next exit, and I
roll my car into a Getty station.
And as I park the car,
I'm angry, and I'm sad.
I'm 20 years old.
I'm a McDonald's manager.
I make $7.25 an hour, and I'm
the richest person I know.
My mother is living on
welfare with my sister.
My father's left 10 years ago, and the
only friend that I have who even has
a credit card or a car that can make
this 100-mile trip to New Hampshire
is off on some college weekend,
and I can't get in touch with him.
And this was not the plan for my life.
I was not supposed to be this alone.
And so I go into the Getty
station to beg for gas.
$8 worth of gas is all I need 'cause
it's 1991 and gas is 85 cents a gallon.
And the kid behind the counter
will not give it to me.
He doesn't wanna lose his job, and
I offer everything, and he says no.
So I go back to my car.
My plan is to wait for
the next shift change.
Maybe someone more
sympathetic will take over.
But as I climb into my car, I see
my McDonald's uniform crumpled
in the back, and I have an idea.
The initial elephant, the question, the
curiosity, the reason you wanna be driven
home to the end of the story is Matt
has a flat tire, and he has no money.
How will he get home?
That is the stake.
That is the elephant at the beginning
of the story that will grab your
attention and cause you to wonder,
how will this problem be solved?
If you're a problem solver, the
kind of person that likes to puzzle
things out, you might have actually
started to think about solutions
for me, solutions on my behalf.
Something that happened 30 years ago
you're worried about now and wondering
how I was gonna get out of it.
The goal of an elephant is to
give an audience a reason to be
immediately invested in the story.
How will Matt get out of New Hampshire?
An hour later, I'm in a
residential neighborhood about
a mile from the Getty station.
I'm on the porch of a red brick
house, and I'm knocking on the door.
I'm wearing my McDonald's uniform, the
blue shirt, the blue pants, the blue tie.
The door opens, and there's a man
standing in front of me, and I know at
that moment that this is a bad idea.
But it's 3:00 on a Sunday
afternoon, and I'm on his porch in
a McDonald's uniform, and the only
way to get off is to go forward.
So I say to him, "My name is Matt.
I'm collecting money for the Ronald
McDonald Children's Charities. Can
you please make a donation?" And this
man stares at me like Stonehenge.
He does not move.
He's 50, but he might as well be 500.
He is all of the wisdom and knowledge
of the world wrapped into one man,
and I know he knows I'm lying.
And the next words that come
out of my mouth I don't expect.
I say, "My mom died of cancer when I was
young- … and my sister has cancer now,
and I'm just trying to do what I can to
help." And he looks at me and points and
says, "You stay right there." And he goes
back into the house and closes the door.
And I know that he's calling the police,
and I'm going to get arrested for stealing
money from McDonald's, which ironically
two years later will actually happen.
But not on this day.
Because he comes back to the door and he
has $20 in his hand, which is like $20,000
to me on this day, and he presses it into
my palm and I say, "No, that's too much."
And he says to me, "My wife died of cancer
five years ago, and I think this is a
really bad idea I had." And before I know
it, I am sitting on the porch with this
man, and he asks me about what my mother
died of, and I say breast cancer 'cause
it's the first one that pops to my mind.
And he says, "What does your sister have?"
And I say leukemia, which I don't actually
know is a cancer, but I know kids get it.
And he tells me that his wife
Lisa died of lung cancer and that
his kids live on the West Coast.
And he tells me how she struggled
for two years and how he wanted to
tell her it was okay to go, but he
couldn't, and how badly he felt that
he watched her struggle for so long.
And I sat on that porch and I listened
to him and I prayed he wouldn't ask me
anything, and I just wanted to get off.
And so finally we were hugging and
I was walking down the walk with $20
in my hand and it felt like poison.
I got to my car and I sat in there
and I remembered how lonely I felt,
and then I felt so stupid and small,
'cause I knew at that moment I
didn't understand real loneliness.
I was a 20-year-old kid with friends
and I was stuck in New Hampshire.
But I had walked away from a man
who was in a tiny house with a wife
that was gone and the kids that were
gone, and he had a loneliness in
him that I would never understand.
And so I put the gas in
my car and I drove home.
But he has always been with me.
I have never left that man on that porch
that day, and I'm hopeful that I'll
never be as lonely as he was that day.
Thank you.
I say that elephants can change their
color, meaning the primary stake of a
story, the primary reason we're invested
in a character, that can change over time,
as it did in the story you just heard.
The initial elephant is will
Matt find a way to get out of New
Hampshire with no gas and no money?
Eventually, that elephant changes colors.
When I end up on the porch in front of
a blue door with a man who's talking
to me about the death of his wife,
it's no longer a concern how I'm
going to get out of New Hampshire.
That stake is now gone.
There's a new stake.
How is Matt going to
deal with this situation?
But there has to be that
elephant in a story all the time.
There has to be a reason that the
audience is invested in what is
happening to the character, the
product, the company, the CEO.
Whoever is speaking, there
has to be an elephant.
When Steve Jobs takes the stage and says-
This is a day I've been looking
forward to for two and a half years.
"I have been waiting two and a half years
to tell you this." That's the elephant.
It is, "I have news that's going
to blow you away. I have been
waiting a long time to share this
with you." That is the elephant.
We must open our stories with an elephant.
The other stakes I'm gonna
discuss, they're all optional,
but this one is essential.
We have to have something to invest
our audience in, to make them feel
like they are with us and that they
wanna get to the end to find out
how things are going to turn out.
We open with an elephant,
the first and most important
stake in every story we tell.